well 26 there are different
circumstances
it'd be totally awesome summer begins
it's time to live up to our name this is
our Hail Mary
the endgame finding teams you know your
missions look out for each other
Oh God what's up regular-sized man
avengers endgame rated pg-13
tickets on sale now how's it going
everybody it's Warren and we are just
getting a ton of new promotional spots
and TV spots for Avengers endgame all of
which have a little bit of new footage
and we're probably going to get a new TV
spot every day or every other day
leading up to the movie this new TV spot
has a few new scenes some are funny some
are really cool but one is a major
confirmation about a scene in Avengers
endgame I'll break it all down in this
video but first if you're new to my
channel I'm giving away a life-sized
Infinity Gauntlet and a glow-in-the-dark
fan oohs painting my globe I bow all you
have to do to enter is be subscribed to
my channel like this video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so the
first scene that we have is of Clinton
Natasha looking out the window of the
ship Clint says under different
circumstances this would actually be
awesome what he's referring to is going
into space and what he's saying is it
would be awesome under any different
circumstance to go into space but in
this particular case he's going into
space to fight Thanos the mad Titan who
just killed half of the universe and
then a few seconds later on into the
trailer we see Clint and Natasha in the
front seats actually going into space
and in the next scene we get our first
action shot of Ronan it's very brief but
it's the first time that we see him
actually use his sword in combat we know
he's in Japan and we know that he's
fighting the Yakuza so it looks like
we're going to see some pretty awesome
Ronan action in the beginning of
Avengers in game now the next scene has
a major reveal in it we have the scene
where the Avengers are walking outside
of the Avengers headquarters at
nighttime all looking up into the sky
but look who's there with them this time
no one other than Pepper Potts which
means that this is the scene where Tony
Stark and nebula come back to earth now
this is something that we all expected
for a very long time we all assumed that
somebody was CGI'd out of this scene and
as it turns out we were right it was
Pepper Potts
we know that when Captain Marvel first
arrives the Avengers see her for the
first time inside of the Avengers
headquarters we know this from the
post-credits scene of Captain Marvel so
this scene means that the Avengers
aren't going outside to see Captain
Marvel return but they're going outside
to see Tony Stark and nebula
and that is definitely confirmed by
pepper potts being in this scene we then
get a slightly different look at the
Avengers in their all-white suits and we
hear Captain America say you know your
team's you know your missions again
implying that they're going to be
splitting up during the Avengers endgame
again most likely going back in time to
different points and then this TV spot
ends with a funny scene new footage of
war machine jumping down and scaring
ant-man
or should I say regular-sized man as war
machine calls him Oh God
what's up regular-sized man so this
machine of Ant Man and war machine and
then immediately after of Tony and
Captain seems to be after the time jump
after the Avengers go and fight Thanos
and lose in the beginning a few years go
by and then ant-man returns after
ant-man returns there's now hope and
Tony Stark realizes that they can time
travel so he calls all of the Avengers
back and this seems to be a scene where
all of the Avengers are starting to come
back to the Avengers headquarters where
Tony Stark and ant-man can tell them
about the plan to time travel
and that's it for all the new scenes in
this new TV spot trailer let me know
what you think about this and let me
know how surprised you were that Marvel
actually revealed that it is Pepper
Potts in that one scene it is very
interesting that they would show us that
so close to the movie being released in
theaters let me know what you think in
the comments down below and again if you
would like to enter my giveaway for your
chance to win a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet and a glow-in-the-dark famous
painting by glow by beau and you can
also find more of his work at globe I
bow comm you can find a link in the
description down below all you have to
do is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]